IAN LAKE: I don't
know about you,
but I like writing less code,
particularly boilerplate code.
Alongside API 24,
we've included support
for a number of Java
8 language features
with the help of
the Jack toolchain.
To use any of
these new features,
you'll need to enable
the Jack toolchain.
All it takes is just
a few lines of code
in your build.gradle
file, and you're all set.
Now to cut that
boilerplate code.
Firstly, you'll be able
to use lambda expressions,
a simplified way of expressing
functional interfaces,
interfaces with just
a single method.
This allows us to rewrite our
onClick listeners from all this
down to something a
little easier to look at.
You'll note that parameter
types are optional.
Here we're using
braces to allow you
to have multiple statements,
just like a normal method.
But if you only have
a single expression,
you can leave them out.
A sister feature to
lambda expressions,
method references allow
you to use existing methods
as lambda expressions,
making those one line lambda
expressions even shorter.
The best part about
these features,
they're backward compatible
down to Gingerbread.
So whether you're building for
the latest version of Android
or not, you'll be able to shave
off some boilerplate code.
This works because
the Jack toolchain
is able to implement
these new features using
anonymous classes,
just as if you
had written the old version
of the code yourself.
That also means you shouldn't
go overboard with using them
in tight loops or anything.
They're still
relatively expensive.
However, if you are
minSdkVersion 24,
you've entered a
magical land where
you can take advantage of a
number of additional features.
For example, lambda
expressions go perfectly
with the stream APIs which
allow you to chain together
multiple operations, such
as filtering, mapping,
or converting into
different types
before applying a
terminating method,
such as sum for a stream
of ints or for each
for applying a lambda expression
to every remaining item.
Oh, and it supports running in
parallel out of the box-- crazy
powerful stuff.
And I'd encourage
you to check out
the docs for all the details,
as there's a lot of them.
Interfaces also got an
upgrade with the ability
to add default method
implementations
and static methods.
This makes it easy to add
new methods to an interface
without having to update every
implementation of the interface
and allows you to play
static helper methods related
to an interface in
the interface itself.
And if you're a
fan of annotations,
and I know some
of you are, you'll
be able to take advantage
of repeating annotations
to add the same
annotation more than once.
Particularly useful if you
have an annotation that accepts
different type elements.
So lots of great
new features, both
in the backward compatible and
non-backward compatible nature.
New tools to help you
build better apps.